là on est dans le sud ouest on va avoir
un joli moelleux on est sur des notes
florales des notes de miel
ça c'est vraiment gourmand et puis si
vous voulez sortir de l'ordinaire vous
pouvez allez donc sur le strawberry
fields julien bailly est dans son
élément parler du vin sa passion et le
faire découvrir aux clients
c'est pour cela qu'il s'est lancé dans
l'aventuré du wine trucks
ce camion aménagé en cave itinérante qui
lui a coûté 60 mille euros
d'investissement un outil indispensable
pour ce tout jeune sommelier de 36 ans
j'aime partager
j'aime comprendre ce que les gens aiment
et donc le vin c'est quand même un
échange d'histoire l'histoire sur le
domaine le travail du vigneron avec la
personne qu'est ce qu'elle aime c'est ça
qui est important dans ce métier c'est
vraiment le partage dans sa cave mobile
julien transporte une cinquantaine de
références qu'ils proposent sur des
marchés du calvados
une première étape qui devrait vite
s'accompagnait d'un projet plus
audacieux ouvrir des bars éphémères dans
des petits villages privés de commerce
[Musique]
tout simplement la convivialité pour se
rencontrer entre voisins et partager
autour d'un verre de vin des histoires
se connaître se rencontrer voilà ce que
j'ai envie c'est d'aller vers les
habitants du pays d'auge bar éphémère
vente à domicile
ce natif de falaise installé à
gonneville sur mer a des projets plein
ses cartons en attendant le sera
vendredi prochain sur le marché de
blonville sur mer